urge pessoal de dizer mais um vídeo e
hoje vou ensinar como fazer me xingue
que dá pra andar o perdedor
eu não tenho vida em si nem fazer marcar
47 gente parava entre 10 e 12 las tics e
pôster foi pensarmos que o país saiba se
você estiver em brincar em casa uns com
os outros é mais que você tem que parar
a batalha pra carregar a arma e isso vai
demorar entre um minuto e 2 minutos
vai entender claro da vossa vos cidades
nem muito bom nem para a espera aí que
eu vou carregar no tiros agora e tauá
isso é uma coisa que vocês fizeram essas
batalhas usem óculos por tensão e se
vocês não tiverem podem usar o estoque é
quase a mesma coisa é como se fosse uma
batalha neve as mesmas a idéia é e não
tinha pensado em fazer uma arma com
carga e que está o resultado é
desvantagem que eu quis fazer um
melhoramento das nossas batalhas
eis me aqui do brasil folha o maio e
depois dobram quase pra linha do mar
deixou a pequena distância entre a linha
vincado ali e no centro extremidade do
folha mais ou menos aproximar daquela
distância cai mais ou menos 0,5 até um
centro tem que fazer mesmo por outro
lado pra ficar simmetry distância
em meio à tensão a abertura tem ficar no
lado oposto à nossa briga e dobram a 90°
exemplo para ficar o cano e na outra
partida guerra nesta parte opcional e
quem quiser opinar é o vosso gosto
quando é que vocês querem deixar para
ganhar mas quanto menos vocês deixarem
melhor seja é melhor porque vai ficar
mais no espaço porém cannon
você não consegue pôr mais elásticos
vejam que eu vou colar um tudo em ao
outro
pensei em fazer parte inicial eo
marquinhos vermelho lugar de vocês têm
por cola usar cola quinto e alcançando
neste projecto porque você usar outro
tipo de cola
embora mais tempo para ficar e
normalmente elas até ficarem fogem
prolongado não devem cair aí nessa
instituição na cola tem ficado no sítio
assinalado a gente puxa e tem vários
partidos lita rifa da égua chamada 5
parece-me foi a queda das folhas e curta
em vários segmentos para pular e fui
fazer força na parte agarrar
isso é muito importante porque a água
vai estar sujeito a uma pressão então se
vocês não fizerem isso não vai aguentar
muito tempo e é sempre bom dar mais um
força usando fita de sempre
é muito importante você escolar esta
partida em cima
isso vai impedir que os jogadores saiam
da arma que ele vai trabalhar ali o
carregador zelo parte da crônica veja
aqui é bastante simples só cortar e
depois prenderam uma para a outra podem
sacola então fita nos fita fica melhor
neste caso é o sinal se vocês quiserem
aprender a cozinhar manhã ou não ou neo
essa é a primeira é só tirar você de mim
quando dá mais jeito
este papel que o pai do fla tem mais ou
menos 10 cêntimos por litro em quinto
hoje mais uma rifa é só encaixar deste
modo e é optar com muita força tem que
optar com força aqui para que seja é
fácil pois é depois de encaixar aqui
vocês porém a mesa para que a arma fica
sentada cair se não tiver apertado então
lá vai cair no chão
aí uma coisa muitas pessoas deixaram os
comentários que criam que o fizesse um
tutorial ensinar como enrolar o papel
com força das rifas ok
naquela comigo vocês querem mesmo que eu
faço é ensinar como papel
acho que é uma coisa assim mais fácil
não sai nos comentários mas falando
sério
só que o hospital naquela parte de cima
e para dar um reforço é muito importante
vocês ponham a fita é para que os
elásticos fiquem bem preso aí vai
aumentar bastante a durabilidade dos
credores
os cortes em um tubinho e ponham cola na
partida assinalado por bastante cola
aqui
e vejo um tubinho não fica centralizado
fica assim mais ou menos 0,5 saint do
centro centro de uma combinação dos
cortes ea distância entre um corta o
outro é reserva e 120 para que vocês
podem fazer mais ou menos o que fiz
carregadores em que a gente para 177
elástico que disparavam 14 tinham sete
espaçamento em cada pensamento e o punha
dois elásticos tudo fica mais recente
para o shopping vai depender bastante do
vosso estoque e fazer isso para todos
especialmente através de folha mãe é
porque falta para 32 elásticos ao toque
para trás e encostar mas vocês já podem
fazer com cada batalha lá em casa é 100
mil inscritos ao e estou a pensar fazer
um concurso
se vocês tiverem alguma ideia de algum
concurso deixe nos comentários mas a
minha idéia é fazer tipo que vocês façam
um vídeo em casa brincando com estas
armas uma equipe sem um jogo é ea
história mais engraçada ganhou um prêmio
que é uma história mais engraçada e não
3 milhões traz isso mas depois eu falo
bastante simples eu assinalei lugar onde
você dobra dava pra dentro
e aí podem colar ou então podem usar
fita melhor saque com cola já tá é muito
importante que vocês passam a escola tem
inclinado que isso ajuda bastante
tirá-los elastix vocês não fizerem podem
não funcionar então fica muito difícil
tirar os elásticos e vejo que vocês
querem quando mais longe para o mais
perto que é bastante simples mudar o
carregador estado quiser ajudar o
canalete voz online se inscrevam para
acompanhar as coisas que eu faço e claro
que tiverem sugestões projeto é só
deixar os convido todos e só obrigado
por tudo
tchau
só com faculdade é bicho